bye
good morning everybody very very happy
to be with you today I'd like to first
do an introduction with the the two
superbly capable members of our panel
this morning first we have young Eun who
yep really arguably might be the most
connected person in senior talent in
Silicon Valley and in Asia I knew came
from Heydrich and struggled days she was
promoted so fast you know that that
nobody ever gave her a business card
because they just kept on pushing her up
but this is how it's been all over the
world unbelievable very grateful to have
King here also we have Evan here who
have you know epitomizes top talent
really so backgrounder led leadership at
Wharton went on to do the same at Google
then HP now leading is a senior vice
president the people work at box net so
literally I think we couldn't have two
better people to have this conversation
today but let me just T up what I think
is the situation we find ourselves in so
for many innovative companies they're
faced with a challenge and the challenge
is that their world is fast and full of
opportunity and the complication with
that is that when you have such high
growth over you know such a short period
of time it's easy to end up hiring good
people or even not so good people but
just not great people because the
urgency to get somebody in and to grow
is so extreme and so the implication of
that not to put too fine a point on it
as Guy Kawasaki put back in 1991 at
Apple he said he said the risk is that
you can experience a bozo explosion so
that you're actually not getting the
best people and they're not getting the
best people and so on in the name of
growth you're not actually developing
your innovation capability in the way
you might want to and so suddenly you've
got a challenge now my position as we go
into this conversation
that anything short of being incredibly
selective on your talent and also
incredibly courageous in pruning the
talent that isn't actually you know the
very best you can have the most
innovative anything short of that will
produce a problem that will will make
innovation harder become a bottleneck
and so what I'm asking you to do over
the next to the hour or so is to ask
questions not just across the whole
range of talent development because it's
such a vast subject but specifically
about maybe two questions and I've given
every person has a three by five card I
want you to write down a question on two
subjects so that we can have a very
robust conversation here now the first
question is any question you have about
how do you get the right talent how do
you find the most innovative talent so
any questions you have around that
around hiring and then the second
question is it any questions you have
about the other side of that tough coin
which is how do you get rid of Kerala
isn't actually exactly what you want so
I'm going to give you a moment to think
about it a question around the hiring
and also the question having paid i say
firing but you know at least somehow
managed him out talent that isn't
probably those are the two questions so
just give you a 30 seconds or so to
write down those because i want a lot of
the conversation to come from the group
I just give you a moment okay so I think
we have enough to go on out i'll ask a
few a couple of questions and then i'm
going to do something it's not so much
i'm just going to have each person ask a
question directly to the panel will have
two or three people ask questions and
then we'll dis decide which ones we want
to actually you know all answer and
we'll go from there okay so so first of
all let's just set the the context again
have you start with evan have you seen
in your experience what we were talking
about a moment ago with this bozo
explosion have you seen a situation
where growth is so large or or for any
other reasons you're hiring out of
urgency but not necessarily the very
best can't have you seen this i would
say a fortunate that i haven't seen it
much as you would expect so both Google
and my current company box know about
the regression to the meeting know about
a hiring these higher disease and are
almost maniacally focused on that not
happening what what I've seen more in
the startup environment is people
growing their roles grow faster than
their capabilities which is different
that they're not bozos they're not but
they sometimes I can't keep pace with
the role requirements of their jobs and
and that's the tricky situation rather
than we were so focused at box certain
way but not bringing in anybody who's
not you know the most amazing person in
the world but but what do you do with
the people that have been there for 44
years who have who are now in big roles
with you know huge responsibilities that
may not have had the time to develop up
to that level as yeah you're describing
so they are they were top talent they
they weren't hired incorrectly but all
of a sudden their role makes them
arguably no longer correct for yeah or
it doesn't utilize their skillset right
that they were great at coming up with
ideas but now they have to manage teams
and put in processes and this is not
their skillset and not some Baylor along
the way talk to us about this first idea
of Google and box being able to sort of
take on this challenge how do they do
that either company we let's start with
box crowd is box make sure that they
really are getting is you set your best
person on the planet how do they do that
yeah so we only have two numbers in our
hiring process that we look at and
they're equally weighted technical
ability which depending on the role
could be anything from actually
engineering skills for for our brand and
you know marketing people it could be
creativity and innovation type of things
for our leaders type roles it could be
leadership capabilities or management
capabilities and the other one is
cultural fit those are the only two
things that we score and we hold those
equally so 5050 just about yeah it
depends on the role right so for leaders
we might hold the the cultural fit more
important because the modeling behavior
and and the impact a leader can have on
the
is greater and how do you assess that
how do you assess how do you make sure
let's start on the cultural side how do
you make sure that that this person
really is a superb fit for that beyond
saying it matters well so the first is
knowing who you are right so you can the
culture for innovation is equally as
important at least as the individual and
you can have innovative individuals go
into a culture where they're stifled and
you can have people who didn't think of
themselves as creative or innovative or
never showed that capability before
enter an environment that really lets
them grow and blossom end and be great
so first know who you are so we have a
very strong culture and we we talk about
it all the time and we constantly refine
how we talk about how we think about it
so so we know what who we are and what
we're looking for one of those values
that you talked about for example is
take risks fail fast and GSD which is
get stuff done that that is one of our
are driving cultural features and we
need to know that that's important and
we need to know we're looking for people
who know how to do that and and then we
have a lot of a lot of probably false
negatives in our hiring process a lot of
people we don't hire who might have been
effective we're willing to not take a
chance on the margin and we we just
stick to people we know can be really
effective and we're doing a lot of
research to make sure that that
continues to be true okay one more
follow-up question in that come to you
can and so when you say we we want to
air on that side of it how do you help
so you know a manager you've had a
manager they're hiring somebody they've
been in the company three months how do
you make sure that they really are
empowered and understand that that would
be the value choice yeah I just had this
conversation this morning so it comes up
all the times the context tell us the
context for that a new hiring manager
senior sales leader at box wanted to
hire somebody and our CEO and and other
co-founder whose our CFO approve every
higher still we have about a hundred
people a quarter so the volume at this
point is still reasonable for that and
the the CEO kind of wasn't approving
this higher there was a question as to
why and so we socialize with all new
leaders kind of what our hiring rubric
is and the problem of regression to the
and the concern about A's hiring these
hiring sees we have that conversation
kind of monthly with all our new leaders
and then I make sure to have that
conversation when it actually pops up
and say hey here's here's the issue in
this case somebody pretty much fresh out
of school don't have a lot of data about
how they actually are in the work world
and so the only data you have is the
quality of their education and how well
they did within that environment and it
just wasn't up to our standards it's a
major in career we don't care as much
about that you've proven yourself at
companies and work environments but
early and the leader was like really we
care about that someone yes so
insufficient data in this case about
well not insufficient data the data we
had was only based on education that
wasn't good and that's a different thing
that's insufficient experience isn't it
sufficient data thank you so much a
young same question to you have you seen
this problem in the companies you work
with this I mean bozo exposed explosion
is a provocative way of saying it but
the idea of hiring for you know out of
urgency rather than out of this is the
right person in this role we had experts
oh yeah I see I've experienced this in
space because I've been working on a lot
of cross-border Asia expansion Asia
especially China and India and other
countries Taiwan Korea Hong Kong
Singapore and especially during the when
there was a big IPO bloom for Chinese
companies recently I think this is kind
of related but the c-fos for those
companies were they needed to speak
Mandarin they needed to have gap they
needed to understand all of the
accounting standards they needed to have
managerial experience and they needed to
have IPO experience well it was very
difficult to find these people because
they not just the industries were
growing but the whole economy was
exploding the whole region was exploding
in fact and there were as a real
scarcity of qualified talent and it
wasn't just this is a very specific easy
to understand example but many many
companies were promoting junior
accounting people to be the CFO to go
public they had no idea what they were
doing is a publicly held company they
had no idea of compliance issues and and
all of the infrastructure building and
the need to deal with Wall Street and to
communicate with the outside world the
inside world put all the internal
controls and and and the aftermath of
that is that IPOs became toxic out of
that environment especially China and
the window closed I mean there was just
so this is a very good example of the
market imperative pushing and then you
know the boards would say well we just
need somebody that can do the job and
then but then the people that have the
qualifications were all mainly
Caucasians who spoke English they
couldn't speak Mandarin in a day there's
no way to bridge that gap so the boards
would say okay we'll go for the Mandarin
because we still need that and then we
will figure out a way to take more
junior people and try to expand their
capabilities but the gap was too great
and so in a majority of these cases
there was a lot of problems and
governance okay and so that's one
example right now in corporate America I
think fortune 500 companies have a huge
problem of their boards because the
economic model of business is changing
so fast and we've had cybersecurity
issues there they have they don't know
the boy many of the board members don't
understand what the digital you know
what's happening on the digital world
they don't understand what's happening
with social network so it's not just
growth its transformation very rapid
transformation so the big drivers of
change or technology you know ten years
ago we didn't have iPads now you can't
imagine the retail world today without
an iPad so think about the revolution
that has happened in the supply chain
the retailer's any industry company that
has to start from that is the customer
interface people are not going at the
stores are just sitting there in their
living rooms buying stuff off there
ipad and then they expect instantaneous
delivery well how do you how do you
manage your supply chain in that
instance the whole world is changing so
I think it's technologies change it's
all the convergence of big data big you
know ubiquitous consumer power
everywhere social networks everybody
knowing where you are and all of this
mmm along with globalization the world
has this you knows Thomas Friedman says
we are now multi connected everywhere
every which way so it's not just flat
but it's super connected and if you look
at the fortune 500 boards and the tenure
of the board members I think that's
another place where you've got you know
the pace of change and the pace and the
imperatives of the market outpacing the
capabilities of the people that are
sitting there in those positions so I
think it's really kind of it I see it
everywhere because it's not business as
usual yeah you know I was a you
mentioned Thomas Friedman and I was
talking to Thomas in in China just I
think last summer and he made this
observation that we've really shifted
even in the last 10 years from being and
everybody knows this but it's almost
feel helpful to name it which is we've
gone from being connected to hyper
connected at just in that 10 years so so
it's sort of the old news is still news
which is this the internet still is
transforming everything mobile still
transforming everything and so it's
creating I think as you rightly say not
just in high-growth circumstances but in
almost any industry a perfect storm of
speed and intensity and transformation
and change so one follow-up question for
you and then I'm going to come to
questions from the group what should
somebody do in this situation choose
either of them so choose china in the
IPO challenge what should they have done
you've got the market imperative you've
got to move now this is urgency what
should they have done in that situation
from your point of view well I think the
people they were able to
really go and get the talent that had
the capabilities or combine people's
talents so that you could bring in a
very senior person either at the board
level or at the VP fi at the CFO level
and then put in a VP of Finance or
controller that you you know could speak
the language and the kind of bridge for
the capability instead of just saying oh
no we need a CFO here this is what we
got and we're going to go with this I
mean that's very short-sighted right so
I think that taking a more strategic
approach and a more creative approach
and a longer term approach if you have
to see two people okay cost you more but
if your company's going to get the
listed in two years that's a huge price
to pay that's right you need to think
beyond the immediacy of what you're
trying to do and think about the
consequences how does I love this idea
you know obviously if strategic you know
management of your talent and thinking
about talent as part of your your
overarching strategy on the idea that
you know the one decision you make about
talent is really you know I don't know
if it's a thousand decisions as a
million decisions made in one if you get
the wrong person you've made a million
bad choices you get the right talent
you've made a million correct choices
but but how does somebody do this it in
I mean it is they're practical you know
insight that you can offer as to how
does somebody in a boardroom really push
for this when all the pressure is
pushing them to do something else how do
they do it is it just courage is it
you're speaking up is it taking your
paws and then having the same question
how do they do on the board the board
members have a responsibility to really
focus on succession planning and look at
it as a very important part of the CEOs
you know performance metric and make
sure that it is a very real and robust
process and not just something that you
pay lip service to us right and a lot of
times the management is gonna you know
they're under a lot of pressure and
they're gonna maybe do something that's
quite expedient maybe or I've had CEOs
that I've worked with that are a little
insecure
and they don't want you know like some
super duper or CFO you know marching in
there and saying what about this in
China what about that you know that
doesn't pass muster and all that so
sometimes it's just trying to like
balance their team and their short-term
imperatives so I think the board has a
very important role to play the chairman
of the board chairwoman of the board
should have a kind of a you know ongoing
dialogue and make sure that the
organization or the whole board I mean
one of the most important things that a
board does is hiring Phi the CEO and
make sure the executive team is up to
their up to keep up to snuff right it is
the role that is the role that is one of
the roles and a lot of times sports
because they don't want they want to be
polite to their CEO they don't want to
talk about what if you get hit by a
truck you know they don't like that it
was kind of like you know dance around
that a little bit and tiptoe and don't
really push for the best and make sure
that it's you know all the functions are
very robust yeah but that's the only way
because it's brutal out there unless you
have the really the first rate team and
capabilities you're not gonna get you
know get the get get that level of
execution known as you say that you can
just think about the you know the
high-profile yahoo five CEOs one year
HP's had some interesting challenges to
every you can see these are very real
issues here in Silicon Valley they're
not these are not hypothetical they're
not just you know just to talk about it
these are clearly crucial to the actual
success of these companies in the
boardrooms you know everybody is really
smart and they come together and then
the whole that body of people becomes as
polite kind of you know less than
effective I mean I is just deplorable
yeah look they don't have the debates
right and the third role of the board
you said you know hiring firing CEOs
making sure the senior teams bringing
the third is to speak truth to power
that's asked about the elephant in the
room the questions that the organization
either might not see to ask or might not
feel empowered to ask yeah they don't do
that nearly enough in my experience and
that is everywhere truth is necessary
everywhere for leadership and the more
you tiptoe around the
more you get this function and you get
cynicism and then you got stuff being on
you know and then you got all this
inefficiency because you're trying to
dance around the thing that you're not
supposed to see it's just you know
that's like a big waste of time I'd say
two things just to follow up on my
question one is everybody is in a hurry
to fill worlds right the pain of having
the roll open is is real and present and
especially when you're working at pace
which every industry is now as we said
it's really real and and never have we
always push back on wait until you get
the right person because the damage you
do as you said before and hiring the
wrong person is several years worth of
damage you have to manage them out
eventually they've tipped their team
over in weird ways it's really bad every
time we've pushed to hold off until we
find a better person it has always been
better that person that we were looking
for always came out of the woodwork at
some point and the pain was real but it
was always better for the organization
for the culture for everything else to
to wait until you find to not settle if
you will you can solve the settling in
other ways you can get a consultant for
three months to advise your junior
person who's not really up to CFO low
but don't don't actually make the higher
until you find the person who fits the
criteria and the the first part of that
which too many organizations don't do is
figure out figure out what the role
isn't what you're actually trying to
hire for you need to spend the time up
front and get everybody together to say
what is this what's the most important
is it the language is that the culture
bit is it the technical capability and
if you don't do that up front you just
turn a lot of hours in debate about
who's right and can we take this risk it
you know I'm not worth it something
that's underlying both of what you've
said and and maybe this is surprising at
some level is is the idea that courage
is critical to this question the courage
to say no to somebody internally who
wants to hire and is in pain and they
need to do this I feeling pressure to
perform the courage on a board to say no
you know what is your real succession
plan we're not playing lip service let's
be serious about it the courage to
remove somebody who isn't necessarily
the right person anymore for a position
at this this is leadership real courage
I think that's required and so it's very
you know pushes the whole subject of
town out
side of some touchy feely thing into
know this is tough this is the real hard
stuff okay so I'm going to go to
questions from the group okay so who has
our first question for for the people
they have to stand out that they might
have the snap actually no okay who do we
have here we go we have a question here
was the question and I'm going to get
two or three and then we'll see where we
go so we have at least two themes here
that I think we'll go with we may come
back to this question here about once
you've got great town in the room what
what do you do I mean you can have great
talent that comes in and then is
utilized that you know massively below
its capability that there are people
that are overworked and under utilized
how do you make sure that great talent
that you've selected carefully actually
is able to perform superbly well first
avenue i think there are a number a
number of pieces assuming you did the
right things in their hiring process got
a culture fit etc the first thing is to
to make sure before they show up that
everybody around them their team members
or the team they're inheriting if
they're in a leadership position
understand the need for the role what it
is and why why we did it right I've seen
too often somebody come in that the
ground wasn't made fertile for whoever
the new entrant is and it blows up
because the team's oh we didn't need
this person anyway or whatever so make
sure that the organization is ready for
the person that you just brought in and
that's true at any level but especially
at a senior leadership level that's
another be poison for second what do you
do on the first day somebody comes in
what's the process of box what how do
you make sure they land successfully
just literally first few hours they come
in sure so so besides all the meetings
they've had with the interviews with
most knowing most of the team before
they get there because of the interview
process we try to be as inclusive as
possible first day everybody no matter
what roller level goes to a shared
onboarding experience so whether you're
the receptionist or the new SVP of
engineering you're in the room with
everybody else about 20 25 people and
you're going through the same experience
we don't give get-out-of-jail-free cards
to executives that they don't have to
deal with that stuff that's for the
the masses or anything and I've been in
companies where they do that and I think
it's a huge mistake right so we start
with we're all NIST together you're not
special if you're a senior executive
coming in so that's important in there
they they kind of get the values the
culture etc and then we do follow-up
meetings with all new hires about a
month later with our COO and CFO talking
about our values and how we make money
as a business and then our CEO CEO
talking about vision and who we are and
what we're trying to be as a kind of
disruptive player in the 110
collaboration space one-on-one
conversation of group Commerce has one
too many of whoever was hired in the
last month yeah but it's it's a lot of
time it's about two hours each of those
sessions and it's so it's very
interactive and personal and then we
have a kind of onboarding process where
we suggest that the the person and the
individual team members meet regularly
that they kind of you know form those
relationships we guide that process we
don't command it but we guide that
process for what suggested best practice
looks like and then we do regular
check-ins how is it working for you what
are you seeing I tell everybody who
joins our company you have a very short
period of time to be an alien here right
so you're going to drink the kool-aid at
some point so in that short time be it a
month or two keep a list of all the
things that don't make any sense to you
they're going to be there what I don't
get it why do we do this in 30 to 60
days ninety-five percent of those will
make sense you'll understand why we do
that there's still going to be five ten
percent that doesn't make any sense and
I want you to ask those questions of the
people or any why why do we do this and
what we might find out in a fast-moving
startup environment is the answer might
be oh when two offices ago when there
was this guy in that role we created
that it doesn't make any sense anymore
right the only way we're going to stay
fresh and and innovate and iterate as an
organization is if we get that feedback
and we're not so nasal navel-gazing that
we think it's all normal so that's part
of it is is leveraging the fact that
their new valuing the fact that they're
new and they don't know everything and
using that to help iterate the system
can speak to the same same question does
mentoring play a crucial role I suppose
we would probably say the answers yes we
just say that but but how does how do we
do that how do we make sure that senior
you know leaders as you're bringing them
in really get great mentoring where have
you seen it done really well well it was
done at hydrogen struggles I had a the
CEO who was my mentor and it did amazing
things for the kind of stuff that I got
to do what did he do what did Tom do
this is Tom frio eyes 35 years of
hydrogen struggles built the silicon
valley office for hydrocarbon strollers
and still you know I was called The
Godfather of Silicon Valley sort of
always out there connected what did he
do for you so he gave me some really
tough assignments in the beginning they
had the Silver Bullet program for
rookies who joined I didn't have any
background in search I walked in there
and is that all we have you know fix
broken searches and it's the rookie you
can fix them and I remember his was this
really odd search called zukin redact
they were looking for GM for silicon
valley and zukin was Japanese and rude
Rebecca Tickell Sherman and it was a it
was a ed a company you know like mentor
graphics and they nobody wanted this job
and they said we this has been sitting
around for a year we don't know what to
do with it and I said look you get to
fix it so I start calling around I
realized oh this is a mass consolidation
mass mass consolidation in the industry
i called it the pacman industry and so I
realized there are a lot of good people
that are losing their jobs and then in
calling around I found out that that
weekend there was an ED a conference in
San Francisco so I went and sat in the
lobby and I talked to everybody and I
solved the search so he said oh this
kyung knows how to do search and by the
way that was not the way it's visited
searcher period but so he started
putting me on to challenging projects
including a couple years into my tenure
there they need to open an office in
singapore and nobody wanted to go to
Singapore because you know people that
are well-known in Silicon Valley and
elsewhere they don't want to leave their
practice and go to some far-off country
so I'd worked in Singapore in the past
and I like this so I said okay but he
put me there and there was a lot of
pushback from the partner saying well
first of all she's a girl and second of
all she's not Singaporean and third of
all you know what are you
my son I said you watch you know and he
had the prerogative as a very senior
person in the organization to give that
kind of mentoring opportunity and air
cover so I think it's really important
if you can and all along anyone's career
mentors can provide incredibly helpful
you know boost in terms of getting you
new challenges and new opportunities and
chances to do things that maybe you as
yourself can't really do for yourself
but coming back to your question
Marguerite I think the culture of a
company needs to DVD find from the top
for defining the roles we are clearly
attracting the best and empowering
people and not micromanaging them and
pushing people as high as fast as they
can go up and pushing responsibility
down as far as you can into the
organization and many many companies
don't have that culture and it's not
defined as the culture you have to
define this cultural norm and have all
the people from the CEO embrace this
otherwise you don't get that behavior
and each manager needs to be there when
they get their performance review and
their bonuses that has to be part of
that performance metric and if you bake
it into the organization like that
you're going to get that and if you
don't you're going to have people that
are you know sitting on top of people
micromanage them doing power plays not
giving people exposure you know there's
that saying under a big oak you know no
acorns can grow well there are a lot of
leaders like that and you have to change
you have to specifically say in our
organization that is not the way to
prosperity and growth and and the
corollary to everybody tries to hire
people quicker and take shortcuts
because they know what pain therein is
nobody wants their own best people to
leave to other parts of the organization
because they know what they have to get
done they know what they're held
accountable for and and so we spend a
lot of time telling our managers what
what you're the sign of your success is
whether you're a net exporter of great
talent within the company right if
people leave your team
go on to do great things even better
things than they did you're going to be
seen as a developer of an exporter of
talent and that's a good thing plus if
you hold on to them they're going to
leave the company entirely so wouldn't
you rather have them in another role
within in this case box versus at
another company or a competitor there's
a theme here I think that's important to
connect to which is that that anything
less than a very proactive dismantling
of hierarchy will produce a shutting
down of capability so if you're not
deliberately consciously putting into
the performance metrics constantly
reinforcing the message you will shut
down capability i mean hierarchies which
is like has a monopoly on almost all
organizational types in business
everywhere will shut down capability in
fact I talking with a CEO recently here
in Silicon Valley and he said those
classic words he said he said well here
he said we don't really have that
problem he said because here he said we
have an open-door policy open da Paz
anyone in the business can come and talk
to me any day get mentoring ask
questions and I and of course that's
good it rather have a CEO saying that
they're not saying it but I said I said
how many people come I said as it here's
my guess there's 30 people maybe 35 in
the whole company that on any regular
basis that aren't on your immediate team
come to talk to you for mentoring he
said he said he actually took a pause
he's like yeah that's about how many
come it is hundreds and hundreds of
people in this company yeah thousands
now this is the problem so I think it
comes back to this idea you mentioned
earlier on King of as somebody goes up
in seniority becomes the CEO that the
amount of truth they're getting is so
much lower than they think because
they're just still being themselves as
one executive said to me I noticed over
time that that's more senior I got the
funnier I became you know that this was
had a lot more to do with my seniority
than my sense of humor improving so
somehow we have to create this you know
dismantle all of these natural barriers
to people being able to develop
there you know to actually be able to be
as capable in their job as they were
when we hired them thank you okay a
couple more questions please from the
group yeah so I mean I'm going to place
that to say not just are you open to it
but if you are open to it how do you
really do that because I know a lot of
people especially in a fast-moving you
know industry there in our track they
don't really want to be on that track
that capable they won't even get through
the screening of their resume for sure
not and yet they're perfectly capable to
do the task they won't even get through
so how do you address that were your
thoughts well I firmly believe in
transferable skills I think it's really
important to a lot to think about what
skills have you developed doing whatever
you're doing and ken ken those transfer
to whatever we need and I think you're
talking about from from the outside I
think but we have the same issue
internally right if somebody wants to
make a change they've only been doing
sales for three years now they want to
move into some other area of the company
marketing customer support whatever we
can easily find somebody from the
outside that fits the job description
perfectly right it's an endless supply
of talent in the outside world so what's
the what's the balance and how do we
know whether we should take a chance
with somebody inside they've proven
culturally and and otherwise that they
can be successful but they have never
done that job before and we our tendency
is to take that chance on the individual
internally and grow and develop them
through mentorship and other things to
give them that shot we can always find
somebody from the outside similarly
looking from the outside I can find
somebody who has 15 years in enterprise
marketing experience versus the person
who was you know whatever an anchor at a
local news station who developed some of
the same skills and abilities perhaps
but doesn't have the proven experience
and then you're looking for what are you
trying to do are you trying to shore up
the group you have with some expertise
that you don't have in it or in fact are
you trying to diversify the stodgy state
approach that everybody else in the
world has by bringing in something new
and I think that the need again for the
role and what are we really trying to do
with it dictates whether you're open to
somebody with a wildly different
background or not give us an example
Evan of someone who internally wanted to
be in a totally different industry
different
industry of a different area within the
company and that was made possible it
does but we have them all the time so we
just had somebody who in our customer
success organization so they do what we
used to call tech support which we're
now trying to modernize with a different
term but you know end users who have a
some question about our product that
they were running managing a team in
there and they they've been doing it for
four years which is pretty much the
history of our company and wanted to try
something else and we took a chance on
moving them into the sales engineering
organization these are the folks who
work with customers to answer all the
technical questions about our product he
didn't really have the background but
certainly had the interest and so let
him go through the interview process he
wowed the team with his knowledge of the
product they thought they could shore up
his kind of technical skills and we said
yeah let's do it let's take that chance
in and see if it works do you think in
box today it is easier if somebody wants
to get on a slightly different or even
very different career track is it easier
for them to leave and pursue that or is
it easier for them to do that within box
yeah and that's that's the question that
i challenge my team on every day right
yes it's if it's easier in the
generalized version is if it's easier to
get a job outside the company than it is
inside the company you're in big trouble
right so if you put more barriers in
place inside somebody will just go
outside it's a hot market certainly here
in the valley and anywhere that we exist
and so you don't want to do that at the
same time you don't want to necessarily
just let people who oh I was the
receptionist and now I'm interested in
you know sales you know you want to make
sure there's some connection to skills
abilities interest career path etc so
you have to have a robust enough process
that you make sure you get the best
person for the role but you also have to
make sure that it's not easier to go
outside to develop what you want to do
in your career and not that's a dynamic
tension that keeps changing based on
individual situations needs and
interests pushing you on it which is
which do you honestly think today is
easier is it easier for people to leave
and get their job or easier for them to
be able to find a sort of next dream job
inside the company currently it's easier
inside and easy I think the question is
are we going to be able to maintain you
do that since we're growing so fast
we're always going to need to hire new
people do we always hire the senior
people from the outside
or and therefore the people inside don't
feel like they have a chance to move up
and have a career or can we take some
chances to move in the senior roles I
think it's harder in the more junior
roles it's easier i was talking to an
executive at salesforce recently who
said that they had set this as a
standard Idzik we want it to be easier
to get job internally then externally
they thought that was an easy pretty
easy standard and they found incredibly
hot I found it was that actually they
say they admit I don't think we have
achieved that it's still easier to get
to the next level I think we're it's
easier but though you know you do it on
metrics as well right so we have a
metric that we want fifty percent of
managerial positions filled from the
inside we Came just short like 45 or
something percent last time around right
so you have to figure out what what good
would look like and then you have to try
to hit that and you have to know that
you might not always get it but that
that's a well that means we have to
train people that means you have to
select people I mean there's a lot of
work behind that it's not just we could
easily hit fifty percent just putting
people in it but the disaster it would
be if they weren't any good would be a
problem so you know hold your pick the
metrics that matter and then hold
yourself accountable to reach you it's
great um okay a couple more questions
okay but listen there's kind of a I
don't know if I can even since since one
thread through that but there is a very
interesting question here about about
ageism I mean obviously today we talk a
lot about diversity but I remember for
example even here at Stanford which is a
fairly you know fair enough pointer to
point to end in the business school we
talked all the time about diversity all
the time massive how many countries ever
becomes from background industry and yet
for obvious reasons the age group was
really similar for the group of people
you brought in and I thought often the
biggest diversity gap isn't just country
to country it's its age its generational
so I think your point is a very valid
one how do you deal with that how do you
do you think about that in your work
first young and they may be here so um
it if people want to become serious CEOs
and their first CEO job they have to hit
it at the time I mean there's a window
you can't wait until you're 15 to get
your first CEO Joe what is this window
whistle so um
I think you have you have to be on you
have to be getting these
responsibilities PL bigger people
geography you have to be kind of on that
on that you know letter yep and so 40
you know I mean 40 to 50 is that window
and it's actually on the lower end of
that right so and then for the startups
it's even lower it's in their 30 so i
think it's i think this ageism thing
especially in a place like Silicon
Valley is very rich is very real and
then in places like Korea they retire
you when you wait by the time in 55
there no more jobs and you better not
even be a sales guy because you know you
have to do peer-to-peer kind of
relationship thing so it's it's very
tough it's very but in terms of the
mobility and and all of that there's a
whole relationship between mobility
Geographic mobility you know industry
mobility and company to company mobility
and America is sort of extreme or has
been any way in terms of the
opportunities for mobility but in a
place that Korea or even a large company
like country like China this thing about
mobility is not robust durability within
the company or do you mean mobility
side-to-side companies outside yeah and
then a place XM like curry if you're a
samsung executive you're probably not
gonna go and become a high-level LG
executive and the families are kind of
like you know the Capulets and the
Montagues right the families behind
these demos so until that gets more
transformed into more you know like a
why less personal less human you know
oriented kind of dynamics that idea of
true mobility and true opportunity is I
don't think it's really going to be
there but it's happening more now than
in the last that's great here ever the
chance to comment here ever Henry a
slightly different approach to yours
actually so I think we look for
very specific things in the companies
that I've been at we look for people who
are learning angel agile who can pick up
new things we're interested in new
things we look for people who move fast
we look for a whole bunch of things that
I know at 21 year olds who are terrible
at and I know sixty five year olds who
are awesome at I don't think it's age
you know technically age but we do look
for a certain type of people that you
that people have I think mistakenly
associated with only it's only young
people and therefore we only hire young
people we have one of our software
engineers who these are in a mobile
product is 65 and he is the most
energetic most open to learning guy in
the whole company right it's not about
kind of actual age I think it's about
how you show up how you approach your
work how you approach learning and that
that were pretty clear on and we're not
going to budge on those things I think
that was the same view that we had at
Google as well what's the average age of
employee at bucks 30 but you would guess
walking around it was 22 right because
of the energy and the the speed and the
and that and that I guess that's why
that's my answer right it's that the the
feeling you wouldn't know that if you
walked through office you'd think it was
22 things even younger which i think is
true have you been to box but still the
average age makes the point did you you
know I think trying to make here yeah
that's a good question i remember as
quickly as you had 32 in a conference a
very impressive but i will say you know
350,000 people across you know so many
countries very different roles i think
it was probably a little bit older but
I'm not that much older day when you
walked into the bottom when you want to
the office you were based here yes yeah
you walk through you see all the
cubicles average age you think was you
probably feel like it was older that's
good it might be the opposite effect but
they get it might even make nigeria vs
the versus the the actual yeah that's
that's interesting okay a couple more
questions here for the group's Evan came
from HP this is I don't so let's see
what's the best way to answer that I we
have I think we have views of companies
that are great producers
talent and those that aren't we're also
trying to our companies trying to do
something different in the space we're
trying to have a consumer approach to
enterprise software as a service so we
actually have people we want to mix
those we want people from consumer you
know fast bit and we want people from
the Oracles and HPS or really figured
out how to work with enterprises and
sell things consistently over time so
we're actually looking for the double
unicorn who worked at HP but could have
also worked at Google and that's that's
the person we want if that makes sense i
don't i don't judge the talent
necessarily from HP differently than
from google but the people who have been
successful in those systems we need the
ones who could have worked in both
systems and that's not always true there
are people at Google could not possibly
work in a HP roared Oracle and vice
versa who do you see as the expedient of
the place to look for town so we like
people from the enterprise companies
sales force is a good model for us
because they're in our space and they've
done what we're hoping to do but they
did in you know ten years earlier than
we did so that's a good place for talent
for us and then you know we like
universe talent so we look at lots of
different companies industries one of my
one of my challenges now is we we know
the engineering space in the valley
extremely well we are highly networked
we know who to look for we know what
companies I feel like we need to jump
networks and start to create new nodes
in areas that we never would have
thought of so I'm constantly challenging
my team like maybe there's somebody in
aerospace who just got the right skill
set that would be interesting for us and
diverse and create a attachment to a
whole area that we don't currently pull
talent from maybe that's geographic
maybe that's industry but I think we get
pretty insular in the valley and a lot
of ways that we think only the people
who are engineers here from any of those
companies are the ones that we would
want to work with and I just inherently
don't think that's true yeah I
definitely feel that there is a barrier
to entry based on where you are
currently living what company you were
in mediately previously it's I think I
think a very different brand you know
evaluation okay couple more questions
wait practices for literally hiring
people yeah exactly without without a
specific think young what are your
thoughts on this I mean where people
to you ords come to you they are saying
this is a position we need filled yeah
well it's hard for me because we're the
only experience I've had is at the very
top at the board level in the c-suite
but there are companies that have
ongoing talent management you know there
are some companies so really want to
constantly have a radar out for talent
good talent and then when i get to know
them and have ways of evaluating and
bringing them in there used to be many
programs like mba programs like when i
got out of mba school there were NBA
executive roles that people and they're
used to rotate you around and then give
you very good exposure to a lot of
things and then you land somewhere by
mutual agreement and opportunity i think
they're fewer of those things going on
now but it's not it takes a longer term
it takes a longer term more strategic
approach to to you know talent so I
think it's only people that have you
know they're not like just operating on
thin margins and just putting out fires
every day they're gonna have that and
you know I mean so yeah I'll give you an
example we in a two week period we
identified at box this was about eight
months ago that we wanted to get the
best the best possible mba students to
apply to box and no technology company
at our size or scale has any kind of
rotational program for real bigger
companies sometimes do but it's only in
finance or sales or so we spent two
weeks and created an mba rotational
program not three nine-month rotations
across every part of the business but we
don't know which ones it's going to be
yet so I own the headcount to make the
smooth the path of you know the
engineering team doesn't need a
headcount to get one of these people
they just need to pitch for an awesome
role for nine months and we got amazing
people 11 is a Stanford MBA we just took
four right there 800 person company we
took four of these MBAs and they're
going to rotate around and in the
interview process we were looking for
the people who could do lots of
different things my goal was sitting
around the executive staff table 10-15
years from now I
people who have worked in lots of parts
of the business because the job there is
to lead the company not to lead your own
function and sometimes that's hard for
people to get their head around so I
want people at that table in 10 years 15
years who have been all over the company
and understand and have the
relationships and don't have the
in-group out-group like oh those guys
over there suck and we're good so we got
it and we're thrilled about it we
launched it in August in terms of the
people actually showing up and doing it
so we'll see but we identify people in
that process who would be great in a
financial but that they didn't make it
into a rotational it's a different set
of skills capabilities mindset diversity
ability to work across ambiguous
boundaries things like that so and now
we're creating one for undergrads
because we had a great experience and
want to do the same thing at a earlier
career level so it's great it's possible
it takes a lot of time and energy
especially at a small scale and so it
doesn't happen that much but it's I
think it's really important that's great
I'd you I will caution you have the
problem of you don't want those folks to
be seen as more special necessarily than
any other MBA you just hired to do a job
or anybody who's already within the
company who may not be having those
opportunities so you have to kind of
parallel create that opportunity for
people who are already in the company as
well as the special new ones you're
going to bring in and that that's tricky
culturally okay this is great we have
about 10 minutes left of this panel so
what I want to do is move to like a
rapid phase so you can ask you a
question you're going to have about 30
seconds I think I have just one of each
of you answer
okay Evan go 30 seconds uh it is often
they don't hear the feedback and they
don't understand so it's worth it to try
to mentor we give people chances to
improve with good feedback but sometimes
it's just not going to be a fit we think
everybody who leaves our company is an
alum of our company there are brand
walking around on the street so we
maintain great relationships about half
of the people that I've had to manage
out refer people to us to work at box so
they've had a good experience even
though we help them see they could be
more successful somewhere else you can
get rid of someone without being
inhumane about it you have to be be
respectful and and value them when you
get and yet so often it isn't done
respectfully so somebody's been in a
company they may have given sort of the
blood at their their life for 35 years
to a company and then they are literally
walked out the door get your boxes you
are leaving as if somehow now your
distrust is almost a criminal I
absolutely seen this I think it's
inexcusable and I don't even know quite
what the logic is that fits it but thank
you for that question next oh that's
interesting the company that is
exporting start uptown young what do you
think about this for management yeah so
the four startups I don't think the CEOs
in that you know the CEOs who are being
groomed to take over GE CEO positions
wouldn't necessarily be right for the
startup see just because they didn't
make it as a CEO they're not going to go
to a start-up and be a start-up CEO
probably not they're probably going to
go to IBM or some other you know big
company like that but I think the
general manager executives that have
really great pnl and geographic
responsibility and have demonstrated
hands-on capability and much more
entrepreneurial and kind of
you know that kind of risk taking
behavior a good candidates for so you
find those people in companies like
Google I mean for example you know
Marissa Meyer came from google so that
there was a cultural fit between yahoo
and google and the kind of risk taking
behavior and she was a moderate level
she wasn't groom for the top and she
would never be the top of google but she
was able to go over to yahoo because
they needed that skill set so so is it
is google the new GE of management you
know sending people out into startups is
google to startups what GE was to
general management yeah well in the
Pacific North West Microsoft is a great
place for for many many microsoft
executives go on to become CEOs of
startups there in that echo system if
you're doing consumer then maybe it's
like Starbucks here you know if you're
in the software industry you're gonna
get software you know Salesforce people
or other there's people or Adobe people
going into software startups so I think
it's relevant to the industry it's not
like general you're not going to pull
general talent over but if you you know
have digital internet e-commerce
location based systems you're trying to
create smart cars then yeah google would
be a great place to get me kind of
senior-level executives who can then go
on to become CEO samsung has been a very
good trainer of technology tongue
they've been very innovative they've
been working on globalizing their talent
for many years almost almost 20 years
now oh yeah well did exporting they have
people all over the world yeah you know
it's not really well you know like eric
kim was the top marketing guy sm so he
became one of the business units for
consumer homes at intel and then he went
and became a CEO of a company called
sora which is a luminescent light bulb
company now he's sitting on board so i
can you see some progression like that
but you don't see mass exodus out of
places like samsung because it's you
know people don't it's hard to replicate
those jobs and as we said before it's
like there's so much ease of movement
among those kind of industries that's
great okay more questions Siri well look
what have to HP you know with each
successive CEO you had massive exodus
right and that massive incoming so
that's the board question you know what
kind of CEO are you going to put in
there I'm okay but you know the thing is
that it is possible to define a culture
that is not necessarily just the total
reflection of the new leader coming in I
mean Google already has a culture and HP
has its own culture and intel has its
culture and sales for says it's an
Oracle has its culture and I think even
if you'd recruited a new CEO in it would
take a while for those cultures to
transform what's interesting is all of
those companies you mentioned our
founder lat except HP yeah and you could
argue that HP has lost sorry wasn't lost
and its culture when they brought in his
first external yeah CEO Carly in 2002 or
amber was right that was the first time
in external an on HP CEO was put in
place and it changed out then I my
understanding was it was intentional
they wanted to shake it up but all the
other ones are actually founder led
companies and that that's that's a whole
different situation is very interesting
the Apple situation is interesting
because now there's different kind of
leader very different kind of leader
inside Apple and I know many people that
went to the stay there very senior
people because you know they said this
is no fun here Steve makes all the
decisions I don't get too but I'm here
because I want to be next to Steve Jobs
this is I'm learning a lot this is
really we're moving the needle and
without that kind of inspirational
leader I don't know you know the culture
of that the cultural definition of Apple
would have to be much stronger to have
it pervade and keep all these people
they stayed there because of the Steve
Jobs culture because now you don't have
Steve Jobs see I don't know what kind of
cultured apples gonna have either well
and so 30 seconds on culture my view is
culture at the end of the day is really
only the behaviors that are
performed and repeated by people in the
company and rewarded and those that
don't happen and or punished right so
the culture is made up of what everybody
does on a daily basis and what's
rewarded and what's shun it's not
mystical yeah I don't think it's I mean
it's ethereal but where you see it is in
the behavior and so the role of a senior
leader to influence that culture is what
behaviors do they tolerate what
behaviors do they reward what behaviors
do they model themselves so the you know
the person who walks down the hall and
sees garbage on the floor and says gee I
wonder why our janitor staff is so bad
versus the one who sees garbage on the
floor picks it up and throws it away
because they feel like they're an owner
in the company that's a very different
culture that forms from that one simple
behavior and and how it's expected and
how its seen so I think that the leaders
can certainly influence the culture but
they do it through how they think about
the behaviors of others do you keep the
person who's killing their sales numbers
who's a total ass who everybody hates or
not that's a very important cultural
decision because are you willing to give
up on the collaborative you know fun
whatever the values are to get results
or not and if you are then the culture
slips a little to something different
than maybe what it was I want this law
here let's just divide it for a second
so there are two different choices there
is the choice of somebody is not a fit
there's a right choice and then there's
how you do it can you do it in a humane
way tell us about a scenario where I
mean obviously no details that we
couldn't share but a scenario that it
was done wrong was done wrong i I've
seen it done wrong a lot luckily not in
my current venue but there are those way
you've seen it somewhere there's flips
switched in people's heads all the time
the person who was on the top talent
list for 10 years and suddenly you're
managing them out and you're like what
what just happened right that happens
all the time in companies unfortunately
and yet you have to say what we were
giving mixed signals along the way or
are we changing what we're doing as a
company and this person really isn't a
fit now but there there's a lot of kind
of flavor of the month when people talk
about talent I I hate that i think
there's good and bad about everybody you
have those conversations along the way
and it shouldn't be as i tell my
managers
women's review should never be a
surprise if I tell our employees if you
hear something surprising in your
performance review then your manager has
failed because they haven't been giving
you regular consistent actionable timely
feedback so you shouldn't get to a
situation where suddenly somebody's not
a fit you get to situations where
somebody's not working out we put people
on performance improvement plans not
because legally it's easier or safer I
don't care about that frankly I'm
willing to take the hit if it's the
right thing for the company to get rid
of somebody we only put them on plans if
we think they can succeed and part of
what always happens we have more than
fifty percent of people succeed out of
performance improvement plans because
there was just missed misaligned
expectations between the manager and the
and the boxer is what we call shell
about what their job was and what so
when you put a plan together you have to
get really specific about that and we
force the manager to get specific and
the employee so we actually have a lot
of saves which is why he were spending
the time you spend so much time
attracting the right people and vetting
them and don't give up on them just
because you know of one bad interaction
at the same time there are people who
don't fit despite our best wedding and
then what why be inhumane about it's a
small Valley it's according to Thomas
Friedman a small world now we think our
brand is walking around as I said before
and and the conversations I have are
typically look you're not succeeding
here you probably sense it we sense it
why wouldn't we want you to think you're
great or we wouldn't hired you so why
wouldn't you want to go somewhere where
you can be more successful it's better
for us it's better for you and then we
do the right thing and making sure that
they can do that in a timely fashion in
a way that makes sense we help them save
you know their their sense of Worth and
their virtue throughout the process
there's no reason to walk somebody how
do you do you don't walk somebody out
under security for a stamp both why we
do you that there have been times for a
security reasons we turn off people's
access after we have that conversation
and we tell them we're gonna do that
it's not a surprise right you have
access to sensitive stuff we don't but
and then we maintain that kind of their
humanity and their sense of worth
through the process and as I said about
fifty percent of them say it was a great
experience and send us referrals so we
think that's a good a good sign we've
never not we've never had somebody not
sign our mutual separation agreement
either so that's a technical version of
that yes okay so let me just follow up
finally on this standard um so give me a
person that is now still kind of friends
alumni of box and what why they were let
go and what you actually did to make
sure that that relationship was friendly
other than just not doing anything you
know awful like walking them at the door
what what yeah so somebody I want to
work somebody on one of my teams they
just weren't performing at the same
level as they used to be we had some
good conversations about what do you
want to do with direct report to you not
a direct report but in my organization
got it um had some good conversations
about what do you want to do with your
life what it and and that person saw
that yeah they weren't performing at the
same level they used to be they had some
other interests we kind of said hey this
isn't this isn't really good for you it
we're holding you back from doing the
stuff you want to do you're not
performing at the level you're capable
of and we need and just saw at one of my
one of my team members weddings the
other weekend and he started his own
companies doing great things he's loving
life that's and he came to the wedding
of his manager right so it's clearly the
relationships are all still intact it's
a great story right and we often we
could have more of those stories if we
spent the time to do it but often we
just say oh they're no good let's cut
them and move on to and there is a time
sink clearly so you have to believe in
that virtue of the outcome that holds
people as valuable and you have to
believe that matters or else you
wouldn't spend the time that we that's
great listen thank you ever so much for
the questions that we've had you know I
think that the panel is bid you know as
I said before you're very particularly
useful for this conversation about being
so selective in the select you're
bringing the town in making sure that
the talent is actually utilized well and
also pruning in a way that is as humane
as possible please round of applause for
both Evan and junk